[Music]
[Applause]
mike florio pro football live co-host
nbc sports joining us on the program
you've been fired up about this taunting
rule here in the nfl how did the where
did this originate from where was the
ground swell mike
well
and i'm fired up for a very specific
reason i think the nfl has done a very
poor job
from a pr standpoint from an education
standpoint from a bracing the media and
the audience for what was to come
standpoint this rule has been on the
books since 1993.
this is at least the second time in the
last eight years that the nfl has made
enforcement of the taunting rule a point
of emphasis which is a fancy way of
saying
hey you officials aren't doing your jobs
right we want you to do your jobs better
we want you to be more consistent we
want you to flag tyree kill when he
sticks the deuces in the face of a
defensive back as if you run into the
end zone because they hadn't done that
consistently so it's not a new rule it's
not a restriction on celebration the nfl
dramatically relaxed the celebration
rules in 2017. this is a very specific
type of conduct that the league
banned 28 years ago they're just trying
to get the officials to consistently
enforce it and it drives me nuts that
the nfl did not do a better job of
explaining it because it puts me in the
position to have to explain it so i bear
the brunt of all the no fun league crap
that they should be taking because they
should have made it more clear and
understandable and i think they would
have gotten more people to buy into it
if they'd done it on the front end not
try to do it on the back and we're not
trying to do much now anyway to get
people to understand it they're just
going forward why don't you taunt the
taunting penalty rule well i'm taunting
the
i brought this up people keep calling me
the old man get off my lawn
uh lamar jackson to me don't a
somersault in the end zone uh that feels
like you're taunting the entire defense
by saying i'm so alone i can flip into
the end zone
uh is that taunting
well
they're focused more on
the actions that are directed at an
opponent or at the sideline it's know it
when you see it you know i remember in
2013 they actually had to explain the
difference between
spinning the football generally
as a show of celebration versus spinning
the football at the feet of an opponent
which makes it taunting again it's know
it when you see it and the problem is
the nfl leaked yesterday to mike jones
if usa today that nine of the 11
taunting calls that have been made so
far are accurate well okay that's fine
two of them aren't that's more than 18
that's not good and then they won't say
which ones weren't tonic well why not
say so so we all understand what it is
and what it isn't this is what drives me
crazy about the nfl they aren't
sufficiently sensitive to what it takes
to get people to understand where
they're coming from and some of the
coaches have done a great job of
explaining this week why the rule is
what it is but that gets lost in the
background people just want to say no
fun league and you want to keep players
from celebrating when the reality is
they want to keep players from doing
something that pisses off that opponent
so maybe he's looking to give the guy a
little payback after the whistle the
next time he gets a chance to do it are
the texans tanking
no i wouldn't say they're tanking
they're going to win just enough games
to screw up their chance to get the
first overall pick i i think that they
they have
a good team a better team than we
thought nick casario the new gm has done
a good job of bringing in veteran
players plug and play get them on the
same page they were more competitive
last night than i thought they'd be with
a rookie quarterback who had four days
to get ready they were very competitive
against the browns if tyrod taylor
doesn't injure his hamstring they
possibly win that game they beat the
jaguars they outclassed the jaguars i
think they have a pretty good team and
they don't need to tank
they're going to end up with enough
ammunition to get a franchise
quarterback in the draft next year if
they want one once they trade deshaun
watson the question is when will they
trade him but i i think that that there
is reason for optimism if you're a
texans fan
and uh yeah the schedule look at you
look at the upcoming schedule there
aren't a lot of wins there but this is a
team that's going to go out and and be
competitive more often than not you have
a column on pro football talk that says
stephen ross
should do the deal he wants for deshawn
watson steven ross of course the
dolphins owner what is the deal that he
wants to do
well the deal is the deal that the
texans want they want three first-round
picks and two second-round picks or
three second-round picks depending upon
who you listen to but
you know this notion that
first-round picks that haven't been used
are treated like this
magical entity and there's this great
value it's like a lottery ticket
sometimes you scratch it off and there's
nothing there and for me it's very
simple the dolphins had three first
round picks in 2020. tuatanga by lower
austin jackson noah igbonogony you would
give those three guys up in a heartbeat
for deshaun watson so why do we have
this
this strange fascination with first
round picks that haven't been used yet
so it's almost like what the rams have
done the rams will gladly give away
their first round picks for a proven
player steven ross has wanted a
franchise quarterback for for years now
they haven't truly had one since dan
marino he wanted joe burrow the bengals
wouldn't give him the time of day he
wanted to otonga by lower that's not
working out he wants deshawn watson you
just tell your people
whatever the texans want go get him
okay what's holding back the texans from
taking that offer
well because
they are
confident they're going to get what they
want at some point whatever the dolphins
have offered so far hasn't been good
enough in the text and say we'll either
get it now
or we'll get it in march
the draft picks aren't going to be used
between now and march and the risk for
the dolphins in waiting is that when we
get to march there likely will be other
teams who say we got to move on from
this quarterback that we have we got to
get better we got to do something let's
get in the bidding for deshaun watson
and the next thing you know you got
three or four teams that may drive the
price even higher so i think there's
value in just accepting the fact that
it's going to be expensive you get a
player who's one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl
and you finally have that franchise
quarterback and yeah you give up some of
your lottery tickets so what look at the
lottery tickets we just scratched off
mike florio pro football talk live
co-host with chris sims i'm i'm having a
hard time understanding aaron rodgers
with the new the new aaron rodgers the
zen mentality
but he's got this zen mentality but he
certainly letting a lot of people bother
him in the media uh what do you make of
aaron rodgers unplugged here after the
first couple of weeks i always hate it
when someone says to me you're better
than that my response is you don't know
me well enough to know whether or not i
am there's a good chance i'm not but i'd
like to say that aaron rodgers is better
than being worried about the things that
people in the media say and he had a
couple of different
occasions this week to talk about it
tuesday with pat mcafee wednesday at his
press conference and
i think that there's a fundamental
difference between opinion and fact and
he has it all kind of twisted together
and he seems just to have a level not
just of disagreement with those who
would criticize him but he's got
resentment there's almost like a
vendetta he wants to de-platform people
who would dare criticize him it's fair
criticism based upon the facts as we
know them to be this isn't unfair to say
when week one looks as bad as it did for
the packers hey maybe all this stuff
going on with aaron rodgers
plays a part in it maybe aaron rodgers
isn't all in he made a rushed decision
the weekend before the start of training
camp he was 50 50
two days before he showed up and somehow
he goes
from 50 50 to 100 like that
these are all fair questions just
because he disagrees with the criticism
doesn't make them unfair questions and
yeah
he's got bigger things to worry about
than what people are saying and he acts
like it's just one or two people there's
a lot of people who are saying this he
just needs to ignore it focus on the
season think about his future at the
appropriate time but why get dragged
down by the haters dan do you listen to
the haters we all have haters life is a
hell of a lot simpler if you don't
listen to them and just do your thing
should kyle shanahan
have apologized to matt leflore for
flirting with aaron rodgers
no no this happens all the time and it
amazes me when
we get these reports breathless reports
the the texans are getting phone calls
for the first overall pick in the draft
well yeah that's how it works the
general managers call
each other all the time and they talk
about different scenarios the reality is
aaron rodgers was under contract and
still is with the packers aaron rodgers
that was well known in league circles
wasn't happy with the packers and i
think the bigger story here is the day
before the draft the 49ers sufficiently
scatterbrained in their strategic
thinking that as they're on the brink of
taking trey lance
they think you know what
let's let's just see if we can get aaron
rodgers instead of doing the whole take
a rookie thing that's what's amazing to
me when they should have been locked in
on their plan and have
a resolute approach they decide
to to throw out a fishing line for aaron
rodgers because clearly they would have
done it if the packers would have said
yes you don't just make a call out of
curiosity so there's no reason for the
package to be upset about it
and there's every reason for 49ers fans
to think boy how committed are they to
trey lance if they were sniffing around
the possibility of getting aaron rodgers
a day before they picked trey lance
have a good weekend mike let's let's let
the blood pressure go down a little bit
okay i'm trying to give you some good
context i know i just worry sometimes
you know you get you getting you know
the taunting thing and it just felt like
it did hey man you know we're trying to
create context
gage is the audience then by the way
what is the halloween costume that aaron
rodgers is growing his hair out for slip
repeat he's slip pete from seinfeld the
guy who helped george steal the frogger
machine look it up slip repeat that's
aaron rodgers
thank you mike see you pal that's mike
florio pro football talk live co-host
uh do you have uh florio's got all that
wine back there i don't think he drinks
it
i think he just whines
oh okay todd there you go